In der Fachsprache wird das mysteriöse gigantische
Nichts im All “Lokale Leere” genannt.
Die riesige Zone kosmischen Nichts liegt direkt
in unserer Nachbarschaft.
Obwohl sie schon 1987 aufgespürt werden konnte,
stellt sie für Fachleute weltweit ein großes
Rätsel dar.
Doch jetzt ist es einem hawaiianischen Forschungsteam
gelungen, diese materie-arme Zone zu kartieren.
Ein spektakulärer Erfolg, der unter anderem
zeigt, dass diese “Lokale Leere” einen
entscheidenden Einfluss auf die Bewegung der
Milchstraße hat.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke - nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Und auf Telegram bekommt ihr die Videos übrigens
werbefrei und vor allen anderen.
Der Link ist hier unterm i und in der Videobeschreibung!
Über die sogenannte “Lokale Leere”, die
auch als “Lokaler Void” bezeichnet wird
und einfach ein riesiges Nichts in der Nähe
unserer Galaxie darstellt, wissen Forschungsteams
weltweit bislang kaum etwas.
Und das, obwohl diese materie-arme Lücke
im All bereits vor 32 Jahren (1987) aufgespürt
werden konnte.
Klar ist, dass ein Netz von großräumiger
Strukturen die Verteilung von Materie im Universum
prägt.
Es gibt leere Bereiche, aber außerdem auch
dichte Filamente und große Klumpen von Galaxien
und Gas.
Heißt also im Klartext: Galaxien sind alles
andere als gleichmäßig verteilt.
Stattdessen bilden sie Cluster und so befinden
sich zwischen ihnen Leerräume.
Ein Teil dieser großen Struktur ist der sogenannte
“Laniekea-Supercluster” - er beherbergt
rund 100.000 Galaxien.
Darin enthalten ist nicht nur der Virgo-Galaxienhaufen,
sondern auch die Lokale Gruppe.
Dessen größten Galaxien sind die Milchstraße
und die Andromedagalaxie.
Als weiteren Teil enthält der “Laniekea-Supercluster”
aber eben auch noch den lokalen Void.
Also die leere Zone, die sich im Weltall tatsächlich
in unserer unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft befindet
- und direkt am Rand der Lokalen Gruppe beginnt.
Von der Erde aus gesehen, erstreckt sich das
gigantische Nichts über 40 Prozent des Himmels.
Nach den Schätzungen von Fachleuten dürfte
der Durchmesser der Lokalen Leere mindestens
150 Millionen Lichtjahre betragen.
Dazu der Astronom Brent Tully: “Unsere Beziehung
zu dieser Struktur ist daher fundamental,
um die Details unserer kosmischen Nachbarschaft
zu verstehen.“
Entscheidend ist nämlich, dass die Materie,
aus der der Rest der Lokalen Gruppe und eben
auch die Milchstraße gebildet wird, wohl
aus der Lokalen Leere stammt.
Erkenntnisse in diesem Zusammenhang könnten
also dazu beitragen, die Entstehung unserer
Galaxie besser nachvollziehen zu können.
Und vielleicht sogar das große Rätsel der
mysteriösen Dunklen Materie zu lösen.
Doch obwohl diese riesige Lücke im All wirklich
enorm ist, ist es Forschungsteams weltweit
bislang nicht gelungen, mehr über diese “Lokale
Leere”” herauszufinden.
Weder seine Struktur, Form oder Größe sind
bekannt.
Dazu Tully: “Der Void ist so groß, dass
er auf beiden Seiten weit über die galaktische
Ebene hinausragt, dennoch ist ein großer
Teil von ihm verdeckt“.
Die Sicht auf die Lokale Leere ist von uns
aus gesehen also verdeckt, weil sie sich hinter
der zentralen Masse unserer Galaxie befindet.
Und so ist die aktuelle Studie ein riesiger
Erfolg.
Denn den Fachleuten ist es tatsächlich gelungen,
die “Lokale Leere” mit Hilfe eines astronomischen
Datensatzes zu kartieren.
Dazu analysierten sie die Bewegung von rund
18.000 Galaxien.
Unter Berücksichtigung der Galaxiebewegungen
konnte so eine 3D-Karte unserer kosmischen
Nachbarschaft erstellt werden, mit der die
Materieverteilung nachvollzogen werden kann.
Diesen Analysen zufolge besteht die “Lokale
Leere” aus mehreren Unterbereichen, die
wirklich extrem leer sind.
Der lokale Void umfasst im Gesamten einen
Raumbereich von unglaublichen 200.000 Kubikmegaparsec.
Parsec steht übrigens für “parallax second”
und ist ein astronomisches Längenmaß: 1
Parsec entspricht etwa 3,26 Lichtjahren.
Und noch mehr: Die lokale Leere ist ein offensichtlich
Teil eines Netzes aus kosmischen Voids, denn
sie scheint mit zwei noch größeren Vois
verbunden zu sein.
Durchaus überrascht ist das Forschungsteam
von der Erkenntnis, dass die Lokale Gruppe
und die Milchstraße zu einer Materie-Brücke
gehören, die sich quer durch die “Lokale
Leere” zieht.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Ein sehr
dünnes Filament reicht vom Virgo-Cluster
zum Perseus-Cluster und überspannt dabei
auf dramatische Weise ein tiefes Minimum im
lokalen Void.
Den Beginn dieses Filaments bildet die lokale
Schicht, die auch die Milchstraße umfasst.“
Heißt also im Klartext :Unsere Galaxie befindet
sich auf einer schmalen Materie-Brücke, die
sich durch die “Lokale Leere” zieht.
Diese dünne Brücke umfasst eine ganze Kette
von Galaxien und zieht durch die leerste Stelle
der “Lokalen Leere”.
Dazu das Astronomie-Team: “Wir leben direkt
am Rand einer Leere“.
Eine Erkenntnis, die wirklich folgenreich
ist.
Denn die gigantische Lücke beeinflusst die
Bewegung der MIlchstraße in großem Ausmaß.
Mit bis zu 250 Kilometern pro Sekunde wird
unsere Heimatgalaxie von ihr weggestoßen.
Die “Lokale Leere” wirkt also als abstoßender
Pol.
Die Fachleute vermuten jetzt, dass es sich
bei dieser Lücke um den sogenannten “Dipole
Repeller” handelt.
Dieser abstoßende Pol im Kosmos wurde vor
einigen Jahren aufgespürt.
Damals wurde die Vermutung aufgestellt, dass
er verantwortlich für die Bewegung unserer
Milchstraße ist.
Die aktuelle Studie legt jetzt nahe, dass
die “Lokale Leere” zusammen mit der anziehenden
Wirkung des Virgo-Superclusters rund die Hälfte
der relativen Bewegung unserer Galaxie bewirkt.
Das könnte also ein Hinweis auf ein großes
ungelöstes Rätsel der Astronomie sein: Forschungsteams
weltweit tüfteln schon seit langer Zeit,
warum die Bewegungen der Andromeda-Galaxie,
der Milchstraße und anderen benachbarten
kleineres Galaxien so sind, wie sie eben sind.
Deren Geschwindigkeiten weichen nämlich 600
Kilometer pro Sekunde von der allgemeinen
Expansionsgeschwindigkeit des Universums ab.
Somit ist also nicht nur die gesamte Expansion
des Universums entscheidend für die Bewegung
von Galaxien - auch die Schwerkraft der Nachbarn
spielt eine entscheidende Rolle.
So bewegen sich Galaxien hin zu dichteren
Regionen des Universums und weg von leeren
Räumen.
Eine Folge davon: Die Leerräume werden immer
größer!
Ist ja auch logisch: Gravitation führt zur
Verdichtung von Materie.
Leere Bereich müssen also immer leerer werden.
Gibt es Beweise für ein Paralleluniversum?
Megacooles Video von Marius angeschrien Unbedingt
anklicken, anschauen und Marius angeschrien
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!